tourist traps is so damn fun we are in
San Francisco vacation and with my
brother
with the SoCal girl doing it Dora cow
shoulda brought that sleeping bag jacket
it's not that bad it'll be
like our first trip together ever yeah
mom and dad is the first grown-up trip
you your first grown-up trip with your
brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
run a bike tour I've noticed
today we're on a bike tour of San Fran
in the Mission District oh yeah in the
Mission District listen miss indistinct
try it with the book Oh yummy living in
LA oh it's that la was a huge mecca for
Mexican culture and then kind of riding
through San Francisco now I'm like oh
that's that's kinda line in Mexico yeah
you taught me something I didn't know
about California which was the fact that
in LA it's mainly Baja California
cuisine and like Mexicans and then an SF
it's more of where my family comes from
which is like I do
I don't know like the first time I
visited as stuff I think I was 18 19 I
immediately fell in love with the city
I was just like oh my goodness I gotta
live here and I bought a whole bunch of
Golden Gate Bridge artwork and stuff
and I hung it up all over my tiny little
apartment and I'm like I want to live
you're so bad but then I realized I
could never live here because I'm too
much of a SoCal girl that I can't handle
that no rather jacket they pick it off
for Speicher I love like the San
Francisco vibe was like the architecture
and everything about it is just so
beautiful like I'm hearing I'm just like
just feel still wins that goal here like
I don't know you know that the
architecture interviews like all the
hills it's just really nice I love
city beautiful
[Music]
you look so beautiful Tish here we
actually brought Rilakkuma on this trip
this is the first time we ever traveled
with Rilakkuma oh it's not oh I forgot
it so Carrie so we've been here for two
days now and I feel like we haven't done
anything yet but we've actually got a
lot what have we done uh I mean just you
know local sightseeing that's true so
this trip it's not our first time in San
Francisco but it's it's been a while and
we've haven't set foot on Fisherman's
Wharf from all the uber drivers we've
had and lyft drivers we've had that
seems like a very good thing to be doing
avoid Fisherman's Wharf everyone's
commending us for not going there so
we're yeah we're doing the more more
locals see we're hanging out we're
hanging out of the spots that they
recommend this to yeah I don't know I'm
conflicted now then because we're doing
what the locals are doing but I don't
feel like I'm getting in San Francisco
experience because it just feels like
I'm in LA and we're just going out
drinking which you can do that anywhere
in the world seeing the stuff that San
Francisco is exactly known for yeah
they're not internationally known for
the things we're doing but they're also
the things that the locals do so it's
kinda like a catch-22 do you want the
San Francisco experience or do you want
the San Francisco experiencing I mean
it's kind of hard to pick I mean I think
today we're gonna see more of a touristy
stuff sort of like Golden Gate Bridge
true yeah we are doing it today
Chinatown maybe I don't know so
apparently we're staying in the second
Chinatown in San Francisco we're in the
what's this area called sunset area
there's a lot of like Hong Kong cafes
and bakeries and stuff like that here so
we got our we got our dose of Chinatown
foods here so which made going to
Chinatown a little less necessary I
guess I don't know it's part of the
reason why I would go to Chinatown just
for the food but we already have the
food here we've gone drinking the past
two nights and the alcohol and the sugar
and the drinks have taken its toll on my
face just less chiseled
I thought I'd use immunity yesterday oh
yeah it is Oh warm and fuzzy I love it
moving you trip on that I know I'm not
looking where I'm filming them shaky
anyway I give up what are you doing
she's starting to feel the burn while
we're walking up the hill and I'm like
okay hold on
okay there's old people in in city areas
that walk every single day carrying
their daily errands and we're in our
prime and we can't walk up a San
Francisco pill for too much of a city
folk
we liked right we're in the city no that
calls itself city yeah i work toward to
LA for our own good yesterday we're
taking up our bike tour our guide was
talking about san francisco architecture
and stuff and he was just pointing out
how you can tell when how does have like
completely gotten rid of the historical
elements of it like the trimmings and
like this assad top and i'm like i
started noticing all the newer renovated
building and I started getting sad so
I'm like oh they're getting rid of the
history like oops preserve it our guide
was saying that there's a lot of tech
people moving in and renovating all the
older homes and they were calling it
like the tech gray or something when
they paint their house moms are like all
really like muted grades home right cuz
the homes are for like the previous
generation painted a very colorful right
ladies yeah painted ladies that's cool
[Music]
yeah Dolores Park that's a picture I
posted all right it was a mission coming
here because we actually picked a
different restaurant to go to we walked
there because we wanted to be healthy
getting there and it's locked there's a
piece of paper with Chinese writing on
it and I didn't know how to read it so I
asked the guy next to me was like hey
what happened he went out the paper huge
like like that and I was like what to
say Hey and he was like oh it's closed
thinking I read Chinese or something
like I look Chinese or something so now
we're here at a different spot we ended
up in the list to check for this place
[Music]
first place I know it's a lot further
yeah this place is a lot further out
yeah but this is the only other spot I
could find that had a decent yelp
reviews that serve the food that we're
looking for my favorite beverage
[Music]
[Music]
we have made it to the Golden Gate Park
which ironically isn't connected to the
Golden Gate Bridge which we thought it
was we're gonna hike through the park to
the bridge apparently two different
places so we're not gonna - if you're
gonna over it again so so much for the
whole hiking thing today and trying to
get some exercise we end up meaning to
uber everywhere we're still hiking a
little bit yeah a little bit
anything's a hike to San Francisco yeah
anything more than 10 steps the hike for
me not killing all the flowers you're
squishing noise don't be so nice if I
just had a ladder to let go then that
takes the fun out of climbing trees I
just have to swing your body over
there's no we're good for your feet
statistically that's the number one way
to fall off the tree when you say the
words I'm scared yeah an A for effort
he's got he's trying he's trying to make
it fancy coming down I don't know that
was very fancy but let's try to have the
the least amount of fall time true I
don't want to like I don't know do the
whole like awful you know it keeps
warming up more and more every day we're
here a location tag let's see honey you
guys like this yesterday I tagged a
geotag Dolores Park like I didn't think
we were going to spend that much time
there branded it spending about an hour
there and we ran into some fans and it's
pretty cool they were like wow we're so
glad we caught you and I'm like hey I'm
glad you caught us too because we're
about to leave they were really
literally leaving they found us both
times I have fans that found you guys
all the times we were about to leave
because they're - oh yeah right before
we came to the park we ran into some
more fans
perfect timing you're just a vessel
[Music]
it's like every time we blog human
nature you fall
oh it jumped to the tree playing
hide-and-go-seek with you oh my gosh
probably has rabies and stuff
Flintstones meet the Flintstones a
chance
yabba-dabba-doo badoo badoo that spot
near you actually we should be good car
yabba-dabba-doo yeah I'm trying to be on
this side we're gonna enjoy this goal
[Music]
[Music]
crotches or yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a pretty nice you look so perfect
like the wave of shape I feel that way
about cats yeah they're like majestic
you're using look stare I don't know
kind of just majestic looking
[Music]
[Music]
we're at the Golden Gate friend
raise the roof and the temperature drop
like crazy come back up here is the
weather Sunday
[Music]
I was about to be some water massages I
know what the massage thing did to my
face
I got a little too relaxed in that seat
well what are we doing now if we're
finally doing one of these tourist trap
things like an oxygen bar supposedly it
makes you have
we get more oxygen and
better for you I don't know I've just
always wanted to try one and see
something like what is it huh
here we paid to breathe
I feel really alert though right now for
real
[Music]
choice is so damn fine really alert like
Harris head massager vibrating thing is
growing my
it feels really good you guys
I had two beers walking in here I was
like a little like feeling good I'm
feeling even better
I don't know what I feel good I think of
you
[Music]
[Music]